for the past few years I've been
spending my summers in the Marine
Biological Laboratory in Woods Hole
Massachusetts and there what I've been
doing is essentially renting a boat and
what I would like to do is to ask you to
come on a boat ride with me tonight so
we right off from eel pond into the
vineyard sound right off the coast of
Martha's Vineyard equipped with a drone
to identify potential spot from which to
peer into the Atlantic now earlier I was
going to say into the depths of the
Atlantic but we don't have to go too
deep to reach the unknown here barely
two miles away from what is arguably the
greatest marine biology lab in the world
we lower a simple plankton net into the
water and bring up to the surface things
that humanity rarely pays any attention
to and oftentimes has never seen before
so here's one of the organisms that we
caught in our net this is a jellyfish
but look closely and living inside of
this animal is another organism that is
very likely entirely new to science a
complete new species or how about this
other transparent beauty with a beating
heart
a sexually growing on top of his head
progeny that will move on to reproduce
sexually now let me say that again this
animal is drawing a sexually on top of
his head progeny that is going to
reproduce sexually in the next
generation a weird jellyfish not not
quite and this is an Assyrian this is a
group of animals and now we know we
share extensive genomic ancestry with
and it is perhaps the closest
invertebrate species to our own meat
your cousin
Talia democrática
so I'm pretty sure you do save a spot in
your last family reunion for Talia but
let me tell you these animals are
profoundly related to us in ways that
we're just beginning to understand so
next time you hear anybody there I
simply telling you that this type of
research is a simple fishing expedition
I hope that you'll remember the trip
that we just took today mainly in the
biological sciences only see value in
studying deeper what we already know in
mapping already discovered continents
but some of us are much more interested
in the unknown we want to discover
completely new continents and gaze at
magnificent vistas of ignorance we
create experience of being completely
baffled by something we've never seen
before and yes I agree there's a lot of
little ego satisfaction in being able to
say hey I was the first one to discover
that but this is not a self aggrandizing
enterprise because in this type of
discovery research if you don't feel
like a complete idiot most of the time
you're just not sign seeing hard enough
so every summer I bring onto the deck of
this little boat of ours more and more
things that we know very little about so
I would like tonight to tell your story
about life that rarely gets told in an
environment like this from the vantage
point of our 21st century biological
laboratories we have began to illuminate
many mysteries of life with knowledge we
sense that after centuries of scientific
research we're beginning to make
significant inroads into understanding
some of the most fundamental principles
of life and our collective optimism is
reflected by the growth of biotechnology
across the globe striving to utilize
scientific knowledge to cure human
diseases things like cancer
our aging degenerative diseases these
are but some of the undesirables we wish
to tame what I often wonder why is it
that we are having so much trouble
trying to solve the problem of cancer is
it that we're trying to solve the
problem of cancer and not trying to
understand life life in this planet
shares a common origin and I can
summarize 3.5 billion years of the
history of life on this planet in a
single slide what you see here are
representatives of all known species in
our planet and in this immensity of life
and biodiversity we occupy a rather
unremarkable position Homo sapiens the
last of our kind and though I don't
really want to disparage at all the
accomplishments of our species as much
as we wish it to be so and often pretend
that it is so we are not the measure of
all things we are however the measurers
of many things we relentlessly quantify
analyze and compare and some of this is
absolutely invaluable and indeed
necessary but this emphasis today on
forcing biological research to
specialize and to produce practical
outcomes is actually restricting our
ability to interrogate life to
inacceptable narrow confines and
unsatisfying depth we are measuring an
astonishingly narrow sliver of life and
hoping that those numbers will save all
of our lives how narrow the us well let
me give you a number the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
recently estimated that about 95 percent
of our oceans remain unexplored now let
that sink in for a second 95 percent of
our oceans remain unexplored so I think
it's very safe to say that we don't even
know how much about life we do not know
so it's not surprising that every week
in my field we begin to see the
of more and more new species to this
amazing Tree of Life this one for
example discovered earlier this summer
new to science and now occupying its
lonely branch in our family tree what is
even more tragic is that we know about a
bunch of other species of animals out
there but their biology remains sorely
under study I'm sure some of you have
heard about the fact that a starfish can
actually regenerate its arm after it's
lost but some of you might not know that
the arm itself can actually regenerate a
complete starfish and there are animals
out there that do truly astounding
things and I'm almost willing to bet
that many of you have never heard of the
flatworm ich mateo Mediterranea this
little guy right here does things that
essentially just blows my mind you can
grab one of these animals and cut them
into 18 different fragments and each and
every one of those fragments will go on
to regenerate a complete animal in under
two weeks 18 heads 18 bodies 18
mysteries and so for the past decade and
a half or so I've been trying to figure
out how these little dudes do what they
do and how they pull this magic trick
off but like all good magicians they're
not really releasing the secrets readily
to Mission so here we are after 20 years
of essentially you know stirring these
animals genome mapping chin scratching
and thousands of amputations and
thousands of regeneration we still don't
fully understand how these animals do
what they do each planarian an ocean
unto itself full of unknowns now one of
the common characteristics of all of
these animals have been talking to you
about is that they did not appear to
have received the memo that they need to
behave according to the rules that we
have derived from a handful of randomly
selected animals that currently populate
the vast majority of biomedical
laboratories across the world meet our
Nobel Prize winners seven species
essentially that have produced for us
the brunt of our understanding of
biological
a view today this little guy right here
three Nobel Prizes in 12 years and yet
after all the attention they have garner
and all the knowledge that they have
generated as well as the lion's share of
the funding here we are standing in
front the same litany of
contractible poems and many new
challenges that's because unfortunately
these felon animals essentially
correspond to zero point zero zero zero
nine percent of all of the species that
inhabit the planet so I'm beginning to
suspect that our specialization is
beginning to impede our progress at best
and at worst leading us astray and
that's because lies on this planet and
its history is the history of
rule-breakers life started on the face
of this planet a single-cell organisms
swimming for millions of years in the
ocean until one of those creatures
decided that I'm going to do things
differently today today I would like to
invent something called multicellularity
and I'm going to do this I'm sure it was
an unpopular decision at the time but
somehow it managed to do it and then
multicellular organisms began to
populate all these ancestral oceans and
they thrived and we have them here today
land masses began to emerge from the
surface of the ocean and another
creature sought here looks like a really
nice piece of real estate I like to move
over there why are you crazy you're
going to desiccate out there nothing can
leave out of water but life on the way
and there are organisms now of course to
leave on land once the land they may
have looked up into the sky and say hey
you asked to go to the cloud I'm going
to fly you can't break the law of
gravity there's no way you can fly and
yet nature has invented more people and
independent x ways to fly I'd love to
study this animal to break the rules
because every time they break a rule
they invent something new that made it
possible for us to be able to here be
here today these animals did not get the
memo
they break the rules so if we're going
to study animals to break the rules
showing how we study them also break the
rules I think that we need to renew our
spirit of exploration rather than
bringing nature into our
laboratory and interrogated there we
need to bring our science into the
Majestic laboratory that is nature and
there with our modern technological
armamentarium interrogate every new form
of life we find and any new biological
attribute that we may find we actually
need to bring all of our intelligence to
becoming stupid again clueless in the
immensity in front of the immensity of
the unknown because after all science is
not really about knowledge science is
about ignorance that's what we do once
Antoine de saint-exupéry actually wrote
that if you want to build a ship don't
drum up people to collect wood and don't
assign them tasks and work but rather
teach them to long for the endless
immensity of the sea as a scientist and
a teacher I like to paraphrase this to
read that we scientists need to teach
our students to long for the endless
immensity of the sea that is our
ignorance we Homo sapiens are the only
species we know of that is driven to
scientific inquiry we like all of these
species on this planet are inextricably
woven into the history of life in this
planet and I think I'm a little wrong
when I say that life is a mystery
because I think the life is actually an
open secret that is been beckoning our
species for millennia to understand it
so I ask you are we the best chance that
life has to know itself and if so what
the heck are we waiting for
thank
[Applause]